Let's Let's I want to go that Islam when
it came roaring out of Saudi Arabia, the
peninsula, it overtook the ancient
Persian empires, Zoroastrian Persia. It
overtook Egypt, arguably maybe our
oldest civilization. Uh it overtook the
Babylonian in Iraq, the civilization,
North Africa, and of course
Christianity, the desert church. We
can't We were a desert religion. We came
out of the desert. It overtook the
Christians in Egypt. It overtook Syria,
overtook the Turkey, where where the
where the where the where the church was
actually quite strong then. The
reaction, the Crusades, to come back,
these two military orders. Give me the
origin of these military orders. I don't
want to give away the whole book cuz I
want people to buy this in droves,
particularly
all three of these books you should get
for yourself to learn, but particularly
uh Defenders of the West and the Two
Swords of Christ for young men. If you
have young men in your family and you're
looking to get them something
for Christmas, don't get them a video
game, don't get them some piece of
telecommunication to they use, don't get
them software. Get them these two books.
I'll guarantee you you'll be shocked
with young men you know very well that
you say, "Well, they don't read
anything."
They'll read these books because these
books are about Christian militant
warrior heroes. Talk to me about Given
that
Islam had come and it just blown through
and was about to go to Europe, right?
That that started the Crusades to take
the Holy Land back. Why did these two
military orders Why were they essential
to that? How did they actually spring
up?
Yeah, Steve. So, um and that's the
important point, which which is why
these books are also important is I
think a lot of people when you talk
about history of Islam and in Europe, in
their mind it always starts with the
Crusades, which means they're always fed
a false narrative that that's presented
in a vacuum. The Crusades started in
1095. What I'm talking about initially
started in 636, okay? And um you know,
this is when I was talking about the
complete ransacking of Christendom and
the conquest of three quarters of it.
And a lot lots of, you know, in one year
alone, in the year 10 1009, an Egyptian
caliph, according to Muslim sources, and
I know people always argue with me, "Oh,
that's No, it's in the Arabic, okay? And
it's well known." He He supposedly
destroyed 30,000 churches, which again
underscores how Christian the Middle
East was. He destroyed them in Egypt and
greater Syria, so basically the Middle
East. And he also razed to the ground
Holy Sepulchre, the original one. Um
okay. So, and this is before the
Crusades. So, you know, and then and
unfortunately, we get people like John
Esposito, professor at Georgetown. I've
I've quoted this uh uh quote that he's
written in one of his books, I think
Islam the Straight Path, so many times
I've memorized it. Um and he literally
says, "Five centuries of peaceful
coexistence between Muslims and
Christians elapsed before an imperial
papal power play led to centuries of
so-called holy centuries of so-called
holy wars that have left a legacy of
misunderstanding and distrust." In other
words, before 1095, the first Crusade,
peop- This is the narrative now by the
academics, so many of them and
Hollywood, of course, is everything was
fine. Muslims and Christians were living
in peace, you know, when they were when
Muslims conquered three quarters of the
Christian world, as I was saying, that
was a the high time of peace until, you
know, the um the the Popes and the papal
power play ruined it all. So, that is
the narrative and that's why I think
it's very important to understand what
led up the centuries that led up to the
Crusades, which was, as Bernard Lewis
even put it, pretty well. He said the
first Crusade was a belated response to
centuries of Islamic aggression. Now,
the military orders come into being um
after right after the first Crusade.
What happened is they've now uh the
Crusaders have liberated Jerusalem and a
few other Christian cities along the the
coast of the
um you know, in what was called then
greater Syria, but today in modern day
Israel and also Lebanon and regions like
that in Jordan. They had very uh uh
cities under control, but the problem
was now that pilgrims were coming in
droves, these were still islands
surrounded by an Islamic sea because
they were just literally outposts in the
Islamic world right now. And so,
whenever pilgrims would come, they would
get savaged, killed, raped, mauled. And
so, a small group of knights decided
they're going to commit their lives to
just defending these pilgrims. Okay? And
they were nine for the longest time, for
almost nine years, according to William
of Tyre or Tyre. And they they
essentially and and they were so
appreciated by the king, King Baldwin
II, that he actually gave them residence
in what was believed to be Solomon's
Temple, which is Al-Aqsa Mosque. And so,
they became known as the Knights of the
Temple or the Templars. And their entire
life was about just protecting pilgrims
from Muslims who would raid and attack
them. And again, what's interesting
about them is is you read the
theological justification for what they
were doing. Um and it comes out in so in
you know, so many biblical verses that
are cited that make perfect sense. They
would, you know, verses such as, you
know, "No greater love does a man have
than to lay down his life for his fellow
man," which of course is often
understood in in Christ's sacrifice, but
that's sort of what they were doing,
too, right? They were following in his
footsteps and they were actually putting
their life on the line to protect their
fellow brethren, fellow Christians who
were coming to pilgrimage, which was a
very important thing. Um and then the
second group, the Knights of the
Hospital, were actually older, but they
weren't militarized. The first military
organization or military order are the
Templars, but the Knights of the
Hospital were actually or the
Hospitallers at the time, these were
just hospice workers, okay? And uh they
actually had a small hospice in
Jerusalem, so when pilgrims would come,
they would give them refreshment, they
would give them beds, and take care of
their medical needs. Okay? So, they were
they were very meek, and the verses that
actuated them were were the ones about
they would actually have prayers about
our Lord's the sick, because Christ
said, "If you do this to the least of
me, you're doing it for me." But then
they realized before long that, you
know, "What's the point of letting these
pilgrims come, get attacked, and hurt,
and then we have to uh try to heal them
and take care of them? Why don't we
preempt it?" So, they too became
militarized and realized that, "Well,
let's nip it in the bud instead of
waiting for them to get attacked and
killed. We will also defend them and we
will fight back." So, they they they
functioned very much like the Templars
as well, as protectors of Christians.
I want to ask you um
as people, you know, thinking about the
holiday season, getting gifts,
what is the most important thing you
think people can get from reading your
third book, The Two Swords of Christ?
And
who was your target and who is your
target audience?
Sir. The most The most important thing I
think people will get is they'll you
know, it First of all, it's a it's a
long, very interesting history. So,
it's, you know, as I always say, when
you look at these histories that I write
about, they're much more engaging and
dramatic than what Hollywood serves up.
The only difference is they're real.
Okay? So, that I think the history
itself is going to be very engaging, but
I think what they'll ultimately get is
this, you know, is this idea of doormat
Christianity, which I think is so
embedded in our psyche that this is the
only real kind of Christianity. I think
this will pleasantly challenge so many
people to see that, "No, I don't have to
always be a doormat. That there is room,
in fact, it's advocated by the Lord
himself to defend and fight and do
what's right, okay? Um Jesus himself is
the one who engaged in violence with a
whip cord, okay? So, you know, violence
is not off the table, it's not the
end-all, the worst sin. Again, this is a
a materialist point of view. Uh so, I
think they will very much be refreshed
and edified by the way the theology was
understood. And again, this was this
wasn't an aberrant theology. This was
widely understood back then, but it's
disappeared and nowadays for a reason.
And the audience I wrote of I wrote it
for I generally always write these books
um for a general audience, but I do
believe younger men are really going to
be the ones who profit the most from uh
especially The Two Swords of Christ,
very much like they would from Defenders
of the West. And just a quick note about
because I would people always ask me
this, they say, "Are they all connected?
Do I have to start with the first book?"
or So, the answer is no. I didn't write
them in a sense that if you don't read
the first one, the second one won't make
sense. But all things being equal, if
someone does want to read them all, I
would start with Sword and Scimitar
because it's the most general and it's
sort of kind of gives you the lay of the
land, whereas the other ones, Defenders
of the West and uh Two Swords, are a
little more specific, but you still
don't have to start with with Sword and
Scimitar. You can start with either one.
I wrote them so they're self-contained
books.
The reason that I I'm so enthusiastic
Well, look, I love all of them, and I
tell people if you want to see what the
country's really up against and our
republics are up against, our
civilization, this gives you such a
depth of knowledge. And I think the
Hilaire Belloc quote is so amazing
because that really was the NATO that
was right after they had just started to
get a semblance, the Ottoman Empire
collapsed, the had the Arab revolt,
Lawrence of Arabia. Jerusalem was free.
Uh Damascus was free finally from the
from the grip of the Ottoman Turks, but
Islam was not, you know, it was the rest
of the 20th century is really very
secularized
uh until the the rise of of political
Islam or Islamism, and it just shows you
it never goes away. It's always a kernel
there, and it's quite dangerous. It is
very dangerous to the West. And today,
that's why it's so important these books
for young men to realize that there is a
history of heroes here that have stepped
in the breach and defended the West uh
over, you know, 14, 1500 years, and that
you are a part of this lineage. And if
you read these stories, you can't help
but be insp- inspired. What's so
powerful about the military orders,
which has always been kind of an
obsession of mine
since I was a a young kid,
is that you're right. It has this
humility and piety and and really
religiosity and spiritualism on top of
being the level of badasses of like Army
Special Forces, Navy SEALs. I mean,
these guys and and the Crusades with the
Army of the Crusades people the First
Crusade was a world historical event. It
changed Europe. It changed civilization
and I can't tell you how much you get
this reading your first book how much it
absorbed the world and absorbed
Christianity. It coming out of that,
these two institutions were really what
was the connective tissue for also the
other Crusades. Because the other
Crusade, you know, there were seven I
think seven Crusades from them. All of
them not successful. But these military
orders kind of hung in there and it's
just an amazing story. I think it'll be
for the audience
especially if you have a young man in
your life you think hey, he's not
focused. He don't go to church anymore.
I he just seems to kind of drifting.
Young men have a certain, you know,
energy to them, a certain
a certain
searching for a purpose, searching for a
task. And that's why I think if you get
these books in their hands, you're going
to see a change of I think you'll see a
change of attitude a lot. They'll say,
"Hey, there's something out there
greater than me just sitting around
playing video games. I see that people
that came before me had this task and
purpose." And that's why I recommend it.
We got to bounce. I'm going to have you
back on. I want to have more of your
thoughts this week about uh President
Trump's amazing
strategic uh cuz it sounded like you
were an advisor on it. [laughter] It the
section the section in the Middle East
and particularly the section in Europe
and the fall of Europe which you've
warned people about. Where do people go
now though to get the books? To
particularly get to know more about you.
Social media but particularly your
website cuz you're a fascinating
character. You studied under Victor
Davis Hanson which is obviously our
audience loves. Uh where do people go uh
Raymond?
Um thanks Steve. The best place you can
go to my website Raymondibrahim.com
r a y m o n d i b r a h i m and also my
YouTube channel. I have a new YouTube
channel which I guess just put my name
in. I think it comes out. Yeah, there it
is the Holy War channel. And speaking of
Victor, whoever wants to see I actually
just he did an interview with me about
the two swords of Christ I think last
week and it's up there and anyone can
see it. As far as the books,
I have links to all of them to Amazon so
you can get them there. And also if you
want a signed copy by yours truly,
you can get it on my website as well.
And like you said Steve, I do think
these books especially the last two and
two swords of Christ will be very very
helpful and edifying for young men who
are dissatisfied with the current state
of the church.
Oh no, definitely.
Let's make these number one bestsellers.
Raymond, look forward to having you on
back later in the week. Thanks for
taking so much time today for our
exclusive show. Appreciate you, sir.
Thank you.